by the way the only reason I give away
all my [ __ ] for free and you know this
is how I roll you benefited from it yeah
it's cuz I know there's only a couple of
you that are gonna do it bingo right
dude I know we're gonna rant it I'm not
at all kind of guess guys its execution
right look guys it's ready ready it's a
good idea to be Ben Affleck right and
what's the other Matt Damon and write a
great script and make a movie called
Good Will Hunting become famous famous
bang chicks make lots of money and have
a great life that's a good idea
good now go do it exactly like I mean
jeez when are we going to understand
that entrepreneurship is a skill this is
like like what are we going to
understand that look now working hard
working smart you can get some a lot of
people listening right now are making
forty eight thousand dollars a year
seventy two thousand dollars a year and
could probably start a business that
makes two hundred thousand a year and
that's great but if you do not
understand that it actually is actual
talent that helps build a ten thirty
forty what everybody needs to do on this
that's listening and that what you and I
have to do the only thing we can really
do is put ourselves in the best position
to succeed to maximize our upside like
let me sing like you know meet me at the
crossroads like that [ __ ] sucks the only
bugs knows how to do it but like like
yes yes anybody can start a business
right good now what what exactly like